hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so we're going to talk about
in this video is how to work with herons
area formula so this is a way of finding
area for a triangle and when they only
give you three side lengths so they
don't give you any angles they don't
give you like the height of the triangle
they just give you the three sides
that's when we can use herons area
formula and what you do is you want to
find the semi-perimeter that's what the
S represents here you add up all three
sides a B plus C right add them all
together divide by two so it's half the
perimeter and then what you do is use
this formula here you take that
semi-perimeter times the semi-perimeter
minus each of the sides in turn okay and
then you multiply them all together so
I'll show you what I mean let's do an
example so say for example our problem
looks like this say it's five let's say
maybe seven and eight those are our
three sides of our triangle okay so what
we're going to do is we're going to find
the perimeter we're going to add up all
three sides so that comes out to 20
divided by 2 equals 10 so that's our
semi perimeter all right stay with me so
far so then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go ahead and put that into our
area formula ok so area of the triangle
equals the semi-perimeter which is 10
then we have 10 minus 5 that's the side
10 minus 7 that's the side over here and
10 minus 8 that's the side here if we
simplify that down we get 10 times 5
times 2 up some sorry times 3 times 2
right and then we take the square root
of that which comes out to what that's
let's see 15 30 300 so square root of
300 which equals 100 times 3 the square
root of 100 times the square root of 3
so that comes out to 10 square root of 3
units squared and that's our exact area
for the triangle so I hope this helped
you understand how to work with herons
area formula better go ahead and
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and I'll see you in
the next video I'll talk to you soon